y seguimos analizando todas las
implicaciones de la guerra en directo
américa de france 24 esto con más
romeros a la mar bienvenida gracias por
estar nuevamente aquí en el estudio hoy
la mañana de jueves las guerras y las
enfermedades lamentablemente van de la
mano como si fuera poco una tragedia y
otra tragedia nos preocupa ahora en
específico por supuesto la situación que
se vive en ucrania pero no es la primera
vez que esto sucede más no hoy vamos a
hacer una sección un tanto particular
porque vamos a hacer un repaso por la
historia de cómo se han complementado
las epidemias y las guerras sobre todo
las epidemias de enfermedades
infecciosas recordemos que son esos
trastornos causados por organismos como
bacterias virus hongos o parásitos y que
pueden prevenirse relativamente
fácilmente normalmente con higiene hasta
con vacunas también con cuarentenas como
hemos aprendido con el kobe 19 pero que
en una guerra explotan todas estas
condiciones creadas por el conflicto
bélico para extenderse tenemos pues
movimientos masivos de gente tanto de
tropas como de refugiados abarrotamiento
superpoblación falta de higiene en el
agua en los alimentos poco descanso mala
nutrición y ésta enfermedades que
aprovechan todas estas condiciones en
ocasiones han tenido un gran impacto en
el desarrollo de la guerra y por lo
tanto también en el desarrollo de la
historia cual es la primera epidemia mar
entonces de la historia registrada en un
contexto de guerra y también veíamos
imágenes no sé si me creo que la de la
segunda guerra mundial así es esta vamos
a hablar tanto desde la segunda guerra
mundial hasta los inicios hasta la
primera guerra que se registró donde
hubo una epidemia en el año 430 antes de
cristo- en atenas y esparta en la guerra
que hubo entre las dos por el control de
grecia fue la primera vez que se empezó
a documentar una epidemia en un contexto
bélico es en este caso era una ciudad
sitiada donde está además llena de
refugiados de pueblos e islas cercanas
les llamaron plaga o peste para porque
todavía no se sabía bien pues qué tipo
de enfermedad eran los expertos creen
que podría haber sido peste bubónica
pero pues ahora se dice que podría haber
sido viruela o tifus se describían los
historiadores de ese momento una
situación totalmente
desastrosa tenían a gente en la ciudad
con fiebre dolor de cuello úlceras jet
insaciable de comer y esto podría
terminar hasta en la muerte de hecho
murió hasta pericles que era uno de los
estrategas y líderes de la ciudad de
atenas hasta 100.000 personas se calcula
que podrían haber muerto por esta
enfermedad aproximadamente el 25 por
ciento de la población y 30 años después
atenas terminó perdiendo la guerra en
parte pues por la 10ma y la merma que
había causado esta enfermedad entonces
marc siendo así las cosas cual podemos
considerar que es uno de los ejemplos
más devastadores de nuestra historia
ahora estamos a tener que avanzar varios
siglos y hablar del impacto que tuvieron
las enfermedades infecciosas en la
colonización del continente americano y
en el genocidio de sus pueblos
originarios hasta ahora se creía pues
que mucho se debía a la conquista a las
armas una mirada un poco eurocéntrica de
la historia pero es que recientemente se
ha establecido que entre
1492 y 1600 fallecieron hasta 56
millones de personas a raíz de
enfermedades que llegaron en los barcos
en las tropas y en los colonos españoles
se supone hasta un descenso del 90 por
ciento de la población algo en gran
parte porque esta conquista fue tan
arrasadora mientras los colonos
avanzaban los pueblos originarios
estaban no solo batallando los a ellos
sino también batallando contra
enfermedades que ni siquiera conocían
qué tipo de enfermedad entonces llegaron
a nuestro continente en ese contexto mar
pues fueron varias y además fueron en
varias oleadas a lo largo de un periodo
largo de tiempo la primera en
1493 fue algún tipo de gripe no se sabe
si aviar o porcina que se expandió sobre
todo a través de las antillas y que
diezmó de una manera increíble el pueblo
está lleno y arhuaco por ejemplo pues de
la región del caribe más tarde 1518
llegó la viruela también a través de las
antillas pero se extendió hasta méxico y
de hecho fue uno de los motivos por los
cuales el imperio azteca quedó arrasado
no la batalla de tenochtitlan de hernán
cortez sería otra si nos hubiera
encontrado con una ciudad que ya estaba
muy muy arrasada por esta epidemia algo
sucedido algo parecido pase el paso en
1530 con el sarampión y con el pueblo
inca en perú los pueblos nativos no
tenían defensas para este tipo de
enfermedades que en cambio en los
pueblos europeos pues ya conocían de
antes sin lugar a duda causaron más
muertes que las que las armas y llegaron
a cambiar el rumbo y la historia de todo
un continente importante decir que pues
al final los supervivientes actuales no
sólo son supervivientes de un genocidio
armado y cultural sino también de ese
10% de población que quedó viva pues mar
muchísimas gracias entonces por hacernos
entender un poco todo este contexto
guerras y enfermedades pandemias también
lo estamos viendo ahorita con la guerra
en ucrania y el kobe 19 marc muchísimas
gracias como siempre mañana nos vemos
con más nosotros pasamos ahora a revisar
nuestro primer reportaje del día